alors je me pose cette question
effectivement comment laisser une trace
sur terre comment garder des images du
monde comme en laisse et aussi de mon
côté je suis dessinatrice pour la
publicité du moins je l'étais et je
passais beaucoup de temps faire des
images absolument inintéressant tu lis
sans envergure sans âme pour des budgets
qui m'intéressait pas se passer aussi
beaucoup de temps à faire un travail
pédagogique qui me passionnait vraiment
sur une petite école de design graphique
qui m'est très cher mais un jour il a
fallu un événement pour que pour que
cette espèce de course folle s'arrête il
ya des moments comme ça dans la vie en
fait où on est ramené à notre propre
réalité
j'ai deux enfants une fille un garçon et
un jour mon petit garçon de un an est
tombée malade en quelques instants le
temps s'est arrêté on s'est retrouvé à
l'hôpital avec la conscience immédiate
que sa vie avait été en danger
bonjour assure il va très très bien il a
20 ans maintenant c'est un grand
gaillard et qui passe son temps à
dessiner donc tout va bien
mais à ce moment là ça a été quand même
fondateur pour moi c'est à dire j'avais
un espèce de carnets qui était d'un
papier que j'avais pas choisi dans mon
sac
j'avais j'avais quelques crayons je
n'avais pas choisi non plus mais j'ai eu
envie de marquer ce moment là alors il
était dans son petit lit à barreaux il
avait un truc pour respirer dans le nez
il était tout fragile et je les dessine
et les dessins sincèrement ils sont pas
terribles ils sont ils sont marqués de
l'émotion du moment et en plus comme je
dessinais pour beaucoup pour la
publicité où on dessine pas beaucoup
d'enfants malades
c'était possédez pas terrible mais il
reste de ces instants quelque chose
d'extrêmement fort et à ce moment là
j'ai décidé je voulais raconter la vie
alors j'ai continué je suis allé voir
directeur de l'hôpital j'ai demandé à
continuer des dessins à l'hôpital et
puis j'ai suivi des femmes jusqu'à
l'accouchement
une dizaine de femmes je vous ai dit les
toutes les séances de préparation à
l'accouchement un grossiste est plus en
plus moi non et puis on mangeait
beaucoup on rigolait beaucoup on était
très ému et j'en ai accompagné quelques
unes jusqu'à la fin et de ces instants
il reste énormément d'émotion c'est
vraiment encore au delà du dessin que
j'ai fait je n'ai pas arrêté de dessiner
pendant tout ce temps là à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui encore et m'envoie donc
presque vingt ans après on voit toujours
des images de leurs grands bébés cadre
on dit et on en me disant exactement
comment il va c'est à dire que ça a
marqué quelque chose en tout cas j'ai
compris que je voulais dessiner le
vivant et des instants et des instants
de la vie
alors parmi toutes ces expériences je
vais vous raconter deux directions de de
direction importante la première c'est
le spectacle vivant je savais qu'il
fallait que je me débarrasse un petit
peu de tous les stéréotypes de la
publicité
donc il fallait vraiment que je lâche
prise un petit peu de choix pas mon
bureau soit mal installé donc je suis
allé dans une salle de spectacle et puis
j'ai commencé à travailler avec des
danseurs j'ai travaillé vraiment pendant
des répétitions j'ai essayé j'ai
travaillé l'anatomie j'ai essayé de
comprendre comment libérer montrait en
fait en étant mal installé dans le noir
en tout cas dans des conditions très
précaires
et puis au fur et à mesure ma main s'est
débrouillé sans mes yeux en fait et en
trouvant une certaine forme de liberté
par chance j'ai rencontré un cirque
magnifique avec trois artistes
magnifique trois acrobates qui comme moi
vous voulez travailler sur un spectacle
qui était fait de dépouillement d'avoir
le moins de le moins de matériaux
possibles en fait pour raconter une
histoire une histoire forte et moi mon
idée c'était vraiment d'essayer de me
dépouiller aussi au fur et à mesure
d'être dans un dessin -
moins codifié avec moins de moins de
petites choses superficielles
donc j'ai travaillé avec ce cirque et
puis peu à peu j'ai j'ai élargi aux
danseurs au cirque et puis j'ai suivi un
orchestre notamment un orchestre
québécois en musique contemporaine et
cet orchestre il gelé suivi j'ai dessiné
toutes les répétitions j'ai passé du
temps à travailler sur la musique et de
fil en aiguille j'ai travaillé de plus
en plus avec des musiciens donc
notamment ma pratique particulière c'est
travailler en direct
toujours en direct jamais d'après photos
mais toujours en direct et en spectacle
et lors de festivals par exemple et
effectivement c'est bien de dessiner
mais le dessin n'a de sens aussi que
s'il est partagé quand on quand on
dessine en direct dans un lieu mais
c'est vrai aussi sur un festival on est
là au bord de la seine on est là dans la
rue quand il ya du spectacle de rue les
gens se s'approche de nous les enfants
viennent énormément les adultes regarde
du coin de l'oeil
et puis au final il se passe quelque
chose entre les gens et nous même
dessinateur et puis et puis les artistes
et nous mêmes
c'est ça c'est très touchant c'est à
dire j'affiche les les dessins au fur et
à mesure et puis les gens se
reconnaissent et à chaque fois c'est
quelque chose de l'ordre du plaisir ou
de l'émotion et ceux qui sont
particulièrement touchés c'est souvent
les spectateurs mais parfois les mets
parfois des artistes aussi quand ils
voient des dessins ça c'est quand même
assez étonnant c'est à dire que de cette
pratique est une pratique très je dirais
précaire traditionnelle et précaires des
crayons de la plume de lancre du stylo
bille enfin des choses très simples que
vous connaissez absolument tous
finalement les gens retirent un plaisir
fou donc par exemple dernièrement à
brest j'ai travaillé sur une nuits
musicales
il y avait de la musique toute la nuit
de la musique classique et je
travaillais je regardais je regardais
tout ça et entre deux de spectacle un
petit dans le théâtre y avait un petit
orchestre et puis les gens sont mis à
danser naturellement comme j'étais là je
dessinais j'ai croqué quelqu'un en train
de danser
franchement c'est 3
très juste quelques une petite esquisse
parce que allait raconter quelqu'un en
train de danser c'est vraiment très très
léger il n'y a pas grand chose au final
cette personne là à regarder le dessin
c'est reconnu alors qu'il avait juste
trois traits était très émue après des
100 photos de l'envoyer à ses copains et
pareil je travaille beaucoup sur le
tango est pareil les gens dansent et au
final ils ont envie d'être présenté un
jour une danseuse qui s'est retrouvé
dans un petit dessin qui faisait genre 3
cm et elle a reconnu son déhanché elle a
reconnu ses chaussures
sa robe mais en presque rien alors
effectivement c'est une question de
plaisir de plaisir que je retrouve dans
le spectacle vivant mais étonnamment il
ya un autre lieu en fait où on retrouve
aussi ce plaisir là une autre pratique
dont je voudrais vous parler je
travaille aux assises c'est à dire je
travaille pour la presse sur des procès
terrible on rigole pas beaucoup aux
assises et effectivement ce qu'il ya de
particulier c'est que ni les
photographes ni les vidéastes ne peuvent
travailler en fait en cour d'assises
donc j'en suis bien contente c'est au
moins un endroit où on a besoin des
dessinateurs on pourrait débattre
longuement sur le pourquoi des
dessinateurs et pas la photo mais en
tout cas là j'ai ma place et c'est une
place qui n'est pas très pas facile
parce que finalement on dessine des
choses terribles au milieu de familles
qui sont déchirés mais ce qui est très
touchant c'est que finalement les deux
familles qui pourtant s'opposent sont
déchirés très souvent se retrouvent
autour des dessins parfois je les sais
je laisse sécher excusez moi mes dessins
au fond de la salle et puis les familles
se retrouvent discutent entre elles en
regardant les dessins comme un lieu
neutre comme un lieu qui n'est pas le
lieu de ce qui les oppose à ce moment là
dernièrement une
un homme avait vraiment enfin il vu un
procès terrible et un homme a pris 30
ans de prison
donc c'était vraiment terrible par la
suite la famille m'a contacté pour
recevoir les dessins pour l'heure en
avoir des copies ce que j'ai fait bien
sûr donc voilà je me pose la question
aussi du plaisir que donne cette trace
qui est une trace effectivement très
légère très rapide bien sûr les dessins
d'assises sont beaucoup plus posé sont
beaucoup plus plus d approche de la
réalité que le que le dessin en
mouvement par exemple qui va être une
un dessin très très enlevé très rapide
sachant que le dessin est là pour le
temps le temps qu'ils représentent 6 et
un dessin si c'est un mouvement qui dure
une fraction de secondes ça sera un
dessin d'une fraction de seconde si
c'est quelqu'un qui plaide à la barça
sera quelqu'un qui sera dessiné d'une
façon beaucoup plus précise
donc je me pose cette question là aussi
de pourquoi ce plaisir pourquoi tant de
d'un plaisir donné avec trois traits et
pourquoi avec cette technique tellement
frustrant alors un jour une avocate à la
fin d'un procès d'assises m'a dit en
rigolant à vous avez vraiment une
technique très traditionnel moi il y
avait mes crayons mais à la fois on ait
une justice très traditionnel alors
c'est elle qui le dit mais à partir de
ça je me suis posé la question de
effectivement de la technique
je me disais aussi que dans les deux cas
ça soit le spectacle vivant où les
assises
on se retrouve avec cette technique
effectivement traditionnel mais pour
raconter quelque chose qui finalement se
rejoint parce que ce sont des lieux de
pleine humanité avec dans les deux cas
l'espoir en tout cas on peut rêver de
quelque chose de meilleur
après un spectacle on se sent meilleur
et on peut espérer que la justice fera
son boulot et que et que que de
condamner aura un avenir meilleur à
partir de cette remarque de 7
de cette avocate je me suis posé la
question de la technique on est
effectivement avec des techniques
rapides et le plaisir dans mon cas vient
quand même essentiellement de du trait
qui se posent sur la feuille et du
vraiment du plaisir de cette race là
mais je me suis peut-être qu'on pouvait
gagner aussi en évoluant dans dans des
techniques plus contemporaine et donc
éventuellement en numérisant le dessin
donc j'ai eu la chance de travailler sur
la sur une création en danse
contemporaine avec des danseurs et en
travaillant sur une tablette graphique
donc mon dessin il était plus sur du
papier il était sur la tablette et tout
était projeté sur le fond du théâtre et
mama peinture virtuelle peignaient le
font du théâtre mais pas d'alcool
beignets le corps des danseurs et ça je
peux vous assurer que c'était
jubilatoire c'est à dire mes petites
pages de peinture qu'ils faisaient était
toute petite elle faisait 3 met 10 m 2
de large un peu de un peu de mégalomanie
quand même mais en tout cas c'est très
jubilatoire et le plaisir était là et de
plus le spectacle sur lequel on avait
travaillé raconter ça racontait
l'histoire du dessin et la façon d'être
dessinés et puis après techniques
traditionnelles ou techniques plus
peut-être plus contemporaine on s'en
fiche un peu
il reste la question du plaisir donc
qu'est-ce qui fait tant plaisir à celui
qui est dessiné
je me demande si c'est pas la question
du temps on à être regardé vous savez on
est dans une période où tout le monde
prend des photos vous prenez tous des
photos absolument magnifique j'en suis
certaine je suis certaine que vous
prenez des photos en enroulant en
courant ou en marchant en mangeant et
puis après voulez vous les fait partager
à vos amis via les mails via les réseaux
sociaux on va tout le monde se prend en
photo mais cela porte le dessin c'est le
temps qu'on prend à regarder l'autre
c'est à dire que on veut pas on peut pas
être pas dessiner comme ça en courant ou
en mangeant il faut se concentrer il
faut donner de l'attention à l'autre
il faut marquer un appui sur une hanche
un écart de jambes
un écart des pôles il faut marquer une
attitude et je remarque dans ce qui fait
plaisir à celui qui est croquée c'est
pas tellement la ressemblance parce que
la ressemblance photographies qu'il a
sur des photos c'est le plaisir d'avoir
été regardée même s'il s'agit juste d'un
appui sur une hanche qui a été bien
saisi ou ou un port de tête ou et même
si le dessin est maladroit en fait et
même si le dessin est raté de toute
façon ce qui fait plaisir c'est cette
attention donc peut-être qu'on est dans
une période où on porte moins
d'attention aux autres et qu'à force
d'être comme ça
photographier tout le temps on n'est
plus vraiment regarder et le dessin
importe ça j'ai un autre exemple par
exemple dessiner des sans abri ceux qui
sont jamais regardé une âme il l'a fait
elle les a dessinés et alors qu'il
manquait de tout il manquait de
logements il manquait de repas tout
simplement de ce qui est essentiel
il était simplement heureux d'être
dessinée même la queue pour être
dessinée c'est à dire que tout à coup on
portait l'attention sur eux alors je
pense aussi que le dessin marque pour
celui qui est dessiné le temps
mesurables et quantifiables même par le
par le temps de la technique qu'il a été
regardée et pour celui qui dessine c'est
un plaisir fou d'échangés et de traces
de la mémoire
donc effectivement il ya cet été il ya
cet échange ce jeu entre celui qui qui
est regardée qui prend du plaisir moi
qui prends du plaisir à stocker des
images qui marquent aussi les instants
vécus qui les certifie presque et puis
et puis vont s'arrête pas le temps mais
en tout cas ça m'en donne à moi un petit
peu l'illusion et ça c'est un plaisir
fou je remercie